[Música]
en Colombia sigue la crisis que se
desató por las amenazas y escuchas
ilegales contra la ex niñera en el hogar
de Laura Sarabia la que hoy es ex jefa
de gabinete del presidente Gustavo Petro
por el supuesto robo de una maleta con
dinero el ex embajador en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti también está
involucrado y durante el fin de semana
trascendieron algunos audios en los que
supuestamente él amenaza con hablar del
origen de 15 mil millones de pesos en
fondos de la campaña de Gustavo Petro
vamos a conversar sobre este tema con
Juan Manuel charri quien es abogado
constitucionalista y también analista
político Muchas gracias Juan por estar
en directo a América y buen día para
usted
Buen día Ángela para usted para todos
los televidentes comienzo preguntándole
Cómo afecta este escándalo la
legitimidad del gobierno Petro el
primero de izquierda en la historia de
Colombia
pues en mi opinión lo va a afectarlo
seriamente su imagen viene decreciendo
en cuanto a la aceptación que tiene la
la opinión pública sobre su gestión y
estos escándalos seguramente lo van a
impactar va a seguir cayendo y ponen en
entredicho la legitimidad del gobierno
Pues bien Juan Manuel Quiero preguntarle
también qué se sabe hasta el momento Es
que este es un caso que se extiende y se
extiende y parece que tiene cada vez más
ramificaciones que se sabe de esta
maleta con dinero que abrió la polémica
y de las acciones ilegales llevadas
adelante a partir de ese momento porque
esto ya evolucionó
en posibles sugerencias de corrupción
pues se sabe muy poco Ángeles Y
lamentablemente pues la información que
nos llega es fragmentaria es de
interceptaciones telefónicas no se sabe
de dónde proceden seguramente serían
ilícitas porque en Colombia no se puede
interceptar una comunicación sin orden
judicial
algunos señalan que puede haber
actividades ilícitas del embajador de
Venezuela
con la antigua jefe de gabinete donde
estaría involucrada la niñera en que se
estaría moviendo dineros de Venezuela a
Colombia Se desconoce su procedencia
Pero serían ilícitos porque se estarían
moviendo físicamente en en maletas que
irían de un lugar a otro pero no hay
certeza sobre el punto bueno Cuál es en
su opinión el papel de Benedetti y de la
obra Sarabia dentro de toda esta
polémica que puede herir gravemente
además la gobernabilidad de Gustavo
Petro
pues lo que hemos visto es que al
interior del gobierno hay hay
fraccionamientos hay enfrentamientos en
un principio se pensó que eran disputas
por espacios de poder pero estamos
viendo que hay cosas mucho más profundas
que pueden haber actividades ilícitas ha
sido realmente vergonzoso ver eh oír
las la comunicación entre el ex
embajador con la jefe de gabinete en
unos términos groseros eh amenazantes
algo realmente sin antecedentes que está
indicando que habría actividades
ilícitas en lo que fue la campaña
presidencial que seguramente deben ser
objeto de investigación por la autoridad
electoral y por las autoridades penales
colombianas bueno Pero además unas
comunicaciones que Benedetti ya salió a
decir que están alteradas que no son de
esa manera y también trinó el ex
embajador una disculpa Gustavo Petro y a
Laura Sarabia digamos por por este
bochornosa escena que él insiste es
falsa sin embargo esta ya es la tercera
sacudida dentro del gobierno Petro de
esto después de dos cambios en el
gabinete y aún este gobierno no ha
llegado a su primer año Cómo se está
limitando su gobernabilidad a partir de
todos estos cambios que hemos visto y
con este último que además de cambio
suma escándalo
Bueno lo que vimos cuando Gustavo Petro
fue alcalde de Bogotá fue una
inestabilidad en su equipo de gobierno
muchos señalan que Gustavo Petro es una
persona muy desconfiada y que a la más
mínima duda empieza a ser relevos dentro
de su equipo pensamos que algo similar
está ocurriendo ahora en su gestión como
jefe de estado y de gobierno en Colombia
en que en que mueve con facilidad a las
personas que integran su gabinete que
puede haber perspicadas ciencias
desconfianzas o incluso coyunturas
políticas Yo creo que con este escándalo
muy probablemente también veremos que
haya movimientos y sin duda veremos toda
suerte de explicaciones Lamentablemente
nos trae a la memoria lo que fue el
proceso ocho mil en el gobierno samper
que hubo toda suerte de escándalos que
terminaron en la preclusión de la
investigación del presidente de la
República en el congreso de la República
Bueno pero usted habla de unos
movimientos que dice hace el presidente
con facilidad pero le quiero preguntar
sobre eso qué tanta facilidad representa
para él porque es un gobierno que empezó
con una coalición fuerte que comenzó con
una gran elección en la que tuvo una
votación además histórica para el país
pero que cada vez se ve más mermado y
que ya tiene sus niveles de aprobación
alrededor del 30% entonces
este gobierno que empezó siendo un grupo
fuerte y grande y cada vez se le ve más
solitario y más aislado Pues usted
piensa que si son cambios fáciles para
él
Pues él tendrá que recuperar su
legitimidad o intentarlo por lo menos si
tiene un problema doble con estas nuevas
revelaciones y es la legitimidad de
origen o sea se está poniendo en tela de
juicio lo que fue la campaña electoral y
la propia elección del presidente y se
está poniendo en tela de juicio digamos
la la legitimidad de la gestión es una
gestión que que ha demostrado no no
tener coherencia no es eficiente no hay
una buena coordinación de los ministros
se cambian con con facilidad Y eso le
está dando muy mal mensaje al pueblo
colombiano de un gobierno que no está en
capacidad de gobernar que tiene
problemas internos y ahora que tiene
escándalos de corrupción en la elección
y en la gestión del gobierno Entonces yo
creo que sin duda vendrán las las
descalificaciones y explicaciones de la
información vendrán Las investigaciones
judiciales y habrá intentos por
recuperar la legitimidad tratando de que
el equipo de gobierno muestre coherencia
y muestre que es eficiente y eficaz en
la gestión
Usted cree que esto que nos describe que
básicamente es un desorden a nivel
gubernamental puede tener que ver con el
hecho de que sea el primer gobierno de
izquierda que se lanza al poder en
Colombia es decir veníamos con una
historia de una cierta manera de hacer
las cosas y este gobierno del cambio
propone algo diferente Pero al parecer
no le ha resultado cree que que hay
relación ahí
Bueno yo yo no lo no lo vincularía con
la tendencia ideológica porque pues se
Podrían haber preparado de una manera
diferente pero sin duda si hay un sesgo
de oposición el presidente Petro viene
de ser opositor lo hace muy bien tiene
un discurso muy coherente genera
expectativa digamos representa un sector
de la sociedad insatisfecho pero una
cosa es ser oposición y otra muy
distinto muy distinta es llegar a la
administración
de las cuestiones públicas para para la
cual parece que no estarían muy
preparados o no se prepararon
suficientemente en la campaña mire una
de las declaraciones más fuertes
alrededor de toda esta polémica que
empezó con lo de chuzadas a una niñera
de Laura Sarabia tiene que ver con el
fiscal de Barbosa que declaró que se
golpeó Colombia en sus instituciones y
que volvieron las chuzadas a la historia
del país en un episodio que fue más bien
sombrío usted está de acuerdo con que
eso es así
a ver en Colombia Lamentablemente
tenemos escándalos frecuentes de
intercepciones telefónicas se llevó a
una reestructuración muy profunda de los
organismos de inteligencia colombiano
desapareció Una institución que se
llamaba el departamento administrativo
de seguridad das en donde hubo muchos
escandalos por interceptaciones
telefónicas O sea no es la primera vez Y
lamentablemente no creo que sea la
última y tenemos ahora más
interceptaciones digamos las las propias
grabaciones de la conversación del ex
embajador Benedetti con con Laura
Sarabia Probablemente sean ilegales y
por lo menos fueron filtradas a la
prensa
sin explicación y no sabemos su
procedencia Y si estaban en un proceso
judicial pues tendrían reserva judicial
Entonces es un hecho reiterativo
lamentable en Colombia de interceptación
ilegal de Comunicaciones
más preguntas que respuestas pero
muchísimas gracias a usted por el
análisis es Juan Manuel charri abogado
constitucionalista de analista político
Muchas gracias Feliz día para todos a
usted también y como de Colombia
continuaremos hablando de todas las
noticias del mundo quédense ya volvemos
en directo a América
[Música]